[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hi everybody welcome back to the data
science hangout so nice to see everybody
if you are joining for the very first
time what is this so the data science
hangout is an open space for the whole
data science Community to connect and
chat about leadership questions you're
facing and getting to learn about what's
going on in different companies and
industries in the world of data science
so these sessions are recorded and
they're shared to the rstudio YouTube
as well as the data science hangout site
which is going to be brand new on the
new posit site pretty soon here but you
can go there to re-watch and find
helpful resources too
together we're all dedicated to making
this a welcoming environment for
everybody so we love when you all can
participate and we can hear from
everyone
no matter your level of experience or
area of work
so you can ask questions a few different
ways
if you've been here before you know the
drill but you can jump in by raising
your hand on Zoom you could put
questions into the zoom chat and feel
free to just put a little star next to
it if you prefer I read it out loud
instead otherwise I love to just calling
you to to read it and and add some
context to
and then lastly we also have a slido
link so you can ask questions
anonymously and Tyler or Hannah will
share that in the chat in just a second
here
you can ask questions these ways but you
can also jump in and add something to
the specific topic if you have other
perspective you want to share it doesn't
just have to be questions we love to
hear that too
um and then if there is something that
you're really excited about you want to
keep the conversation going I would love
to have people connect in the LinkedIn
group too which I'll put in the chat
again in just a second here
but I am so excited to be joined by my
co-host for today Marco suerta data
science manager at Carmax and Marcos I'd
love to turn it over to you to have you
introduce yourself and share a little
bit about your role and background and
maybe something fun you like to do
outside of work too sure sure
um uh hi everybody it's fun to be the
co-host this week thanks Rachel for uh
having me on
um so yeah
um I have a PhD in astrophysics from
Rice University
um completed that quite some time ago at
this point
um I actually spent about a decade
working in Washington DC in science
policy I work for a member of Congress I
worked for my professional society as a
science policy fellow I was at the call
fellow I worked at the department US
Department of energy office of science
for about five years
but as um I had a lot of titles special
advisor senior advisor uh a Special
Assistant uh but at the end I was
basically the cheapest app for the
office of science
um but when that position uh ended uh in
January of 2017 I was kind of looking
for other stuff kind of I ended up
working in the beginning of a part-time
contract gig at University of Texas
Austin uh but I initially I did the data
incubator uh data science boot camp in
Fall of 18 back in the before times when
we could do things in person
um and so
um I can talk a little bit more about
how I got to the point where I could do
that um I you know had I could use IDL
and for my science and graduate school
has anyone ever heard of ideology if you
use IDL in the chat IDL fans like put a
post in the chat but yeah it was this
proprietary see like data language
that's what I wrote like my thesis in so
that was not a programming language that
was going to be of any use to any data
science like job I want
um so I taught myself R and I taught
myself python actually I found my first
commit for a python project just doing
like non-data science and python in like
20. 15 it looks like when I was playing
started playing around Python and then
uh my wife and father-in-law actually
suggested data science as a career track
and I um uh and I started I did swirl
right to use to teach myself some R I
got our studio I think I originally was
using R and then I found our studio
which was much nicer than ours so I
started using our studio uh and
um I think I guess I did the Hopkins
Coursera courses which are kind of like
kind of very similar to swirl right
they're kind of using some of the swirl
uh uh stuff and that's how I because a
data incubator has like a multi-stage
application process where they give you
like data sets and questions and you
have to like type in the responses and
so I used R for all of that right that
was kind of my thing and then I think I
discovered Chinese somewhere in there
and started playing around with shiny
apps just for kind of fun side projects
and then eventually got into the
incubator in Fall of a team and then
well that was mostly a python driven
program but I did use shiny for the my
final project at least for the web
interface with my final project My
Capstone as we called it
um CarMax hired me I got hired by Carmax
on the very last day of the incubator so
we were at the little going away party
and CarMax got a call from my current
boss at Carmax and making me the offer
and I've been there since I work in the
appraisal Lane
um CarMax uh will buy cars from anyone
um uh we obviously use algorithms to
help us make those decisions and those
offers
um and then recently we've started about
a year and a half two years ago we
started doing this online we go to
carmax.com and type in stuff about your
car give us your VIN and we'll give you
a an offer in your car and that really
has been my main focus for the last uh
however long we've been working on that
um several years
um the algorithms the systems behind it
Etc
uh yeah so now manager data science have
been there almost getting close to four
years now before yours in January at
CarMax
so happy to talk about the career
transition stuff happy to talk about the
tools and assistance we use happy to
yeah absolutely yeah okay one one more
quick thing when you do for fun outside
sure
something I do for fun uh it's funny I I
used to play a lot of softball and I was
going to play we had the CarMax finally
organized the game like last Friday but
I was in Texas so I missed it so I'm
hoping that today we'll come back and we
can play some softball in the spring
um I mean everything everything's gonna
be sore uh after swinging about for the
first time in years but uh that is
something I used to do a lot I used to
do a lot in DC I had a team in DC that
was a lot of fun
hopefully gonna play that again these
days I do a lot there's a lot less time
I have a three-year-old so I just want
to spend spend time with her of course
and and the small Windows where there's
calm I yeah lady games or actually just
do a lot of side projects ironically
work with coding and stuff my some of my
work colleagues are scratching their
head that I program outside of work
hours but I do that too
that's great
so thank you for the the background too
and sharing your journey at for some
people who maybe are thinking about
making the switch into to data science
what is like I don't know maybe some of
your Lessons Learned and moving over
sure um so I mean I had a quantitative
you know background you know I I that
certainly helped you know I think um I
think both for you know I don't know how
much it helped with my resume I want you
but yeah I'd done some quantitative
stuff in graduate school I didn't
analyze a lot of data you know I could
put a bunch of big numbers about how
many megabytes gigabytes of data I've
reduced and stuff so I so I think that
helped but I think to me the best thing
about about the incubator boot campus
might be true of other other programs
it's just it reminded me that I could
still learn stuff and relatively quickly
the incubator the way it works it's like
every week like one week is like web
scraping one week is second learn one
week is spice barking it was just like
boom boom boom and um
you know at the end of every week that
was I a master of the new thing I
learned though but I kind of gotten a
decent handle on it right and just the
ability just knowing that I could learn
again knowing that in my 40s not not a
States or can hold on uh that I could
like well it was like 30s back then I
could still learn all of this stuff you
know and kind of you know figure it out
was very you know it's kind of the
anti-imposter syndrome I went from like
thinking well I don't know what data
science is too like hey actually I
didn't kind of pick up anything in a
week yeah if I work on it full time uh
that was very uh very liberating kind of
thing to figure out
um uh but it will sometimes feel
overwhelming like all career changes do
right yeah absolutely so making that
switch over and and jumping right into
the role at Carmax how did you
like find that transition into the
management role yeah so I mean so I
started a senior data scientist I mean
my title was manager but like it's
really more managing projects than it is
yeah people management
um but uh you know the beginning the
first few weeks of Carmax is the
singular scientists were very
intimidating right it was still in
person right like we were I mean people
were nice but I just didn't know
anything right I didn't know what unit
test was I didn't know we're going to
school these code reviews people were
making jokes about how they were working
on unit tests and I'm like what is it
unit test like I mean I knew so little
about anything right so it was just very
felt very
like oh my god what have I got myself
into like what am I doing I'm recording
I do this like I moved my whole family
to Richmond you know my wife was about
you know was pregnant uh so it was just
a very scary like transition um but um
you know slowly but surely I realized
okay I kind of understand this and kind
of getting my hand on that I made my
first little pull request where I
changed one little thing and added like
mean absolute error method so we could
get that to pop out of something and I
was like okay that kind of I'm kind of
getting this I kind of know what you're
gonna test is now and it's slowly but
surely The Imposter syndrome started to
melt away and I realized that I could
all add a little bit here or there
uh so the transition was tough though I
mean like you know we're obviously when
the pandemic hit you know I've been
insulin not insulated but I had been in
non-profits and in government through
all previous economic troubles so like
you know I was not particularly aware of
my job but like you know pandemic comes
stories are shut down
if we can't sell cars we don't have any
money this is like this could be a
problem I think people started getting
furloughed and so that
sort of you know obviously it's just
that was a very not shocking but it was
just a very visceral sort of thing like
when we had all the economic you know
problems with the pandemic related
shutdowns
um so that was very different um but
overall like you know we CarMax had
hired some other phds right before me
and after me so like there was still a
real it kind of felt in some ways once I
got into it and I got into a rhythm the
senior design just role felt like kind
of being back in graduate school you
know I was like looking at data all the
time I was making plots the difference
was instead of as an astrophysicist kind
of tunnel vision on my one little star
that I'm looking at no one else knows
anything about like I'm touching like a
part of an algorithm that like the whole
team is working on right and there's a
lot more
interaction a lot more feedback a lot
more people that can directly help me
right because they know like they've
worked on something similar before
whereas I felt like as an academic
astrophysicist like
I kind of was the expert on this little
thing and
you know yeah I go to a group meeting
and talk about it but then everyone else
went back to work on their own little
things and there wasn't really a lot of
cross
you know connections whereas the CarMax
like Hey we're all trying to
buy cars profitably and uh there was a
lot of good camaraderie I got good you
know especially back in the very
beginning when we were all in person you
know with people looking at my screen
and like telling me and showing me
what's the code where the code lied it
was very collaborative and I was very it
was like a better version uh being I
guess it wasn't for some you know purely
let's figure out how the universe works
sort of thing we're trying to sell cars
but still it was very satisfying in the
end it felt very satisfying like trying
to iterate and solve problems
when you say like building an algorithm
or yeah sometimes I'm like oh the
algorithm like I know exactly what that
means but but like what's an example of
like a project that your team works on
sure so the online appraisal algorithm
is a good example you know um you know
someone has to go to carmax.com and type
in a bunch of information about their
car and we have to figure out what offer
to make on that car
um can't get into the Super details but
obviously there's the machine learning
aspects of that which I worked on and
built out a lot of machine learning
algorithms that could that could help
generate you know that what the value of
that car was worth and that was a a
multi-month effort to kind of come up
with machine learning uh but there was
also like a lot of system stuff because
we had we had to suddenly respond to
like these real-time requests like the
way the store systems work like you know
I don't know if anyone's over solar card
or CarMax the old-fashioned way you go
in they look at your car you sit around
for like a while right like you know the
time the time around the time of the
computer doing something is Tiny
compared to like the time it takes you
to go and sit in the seat and way to get
an appraisal right whereas if you're
doing it online you want to click submit
and see what your card's worth really
fast right so that was a whole new
paradigm of like response time became a
lot more important than it was and our
systems had to be re-jiggered we ended
up using Azure service bus I ended up
writing a ton of azure service bus
python code who knew I was going to be
doing that you know five years ago
um uh to get the systems kind of in line
to be able to handle like this new
paradigm of like Hey we're going to have
to respond to these requests fast and uh
and send back a response fast with our
partner so we're obviously building the
website and stuff
um so it was a lot of um there was some
system work there was some machine
learning there was you know we have to
certain things we want to look up about
the car that we have to go do these
relatively fast lookups and make that
work
um so so kind of pushing all that
together getting all the stuff into
production and all these all these
things production line so that we could
do this live in real time
um but that was you know a big that was
a multi-year process I mean I'm making
it sound like it's just something we did
like it was like obviously we rolled out
rolled it out in various stages but
um
um that was a good example of what I
work on there's other teams at Carmax so
I work on this is the appraisal land
team so we're thinking about how do we
buy cars from like any people on this
call there's also a team that buys cars
from auctions like you know like Manheim
auctions and stuff like that uh and then
there's also
um
a team that thinks about what we what we
price the car in the watt right like
when we put a car in the lot to sell
like what is that price so there's
multiple teams that are thinking about
pricing there's obviously a lot of other
data science teams at Carmax but I am
focused on the team that thinks about
car prices
cool thank you for the context
um Frank I see you asked a question a
little bit earlier do you want to jump
in
and hi hi Frank
yeah I'd love to jump in so like I
mentioned I'm still thinking about part
of our conversation from last week where
we started talking about communication
tools
and Marcus I'm curious when we think
about communicating with your team with
your peers with your stakeholders
everyone uses zoom we're on Zoom right
now everyone uses email there's also
slack but
um
I'm curious is there anything else any
other tools that you use that you've
tried to manage your time measure like
manage how you talk to people
communicate with the folks that you work
with absolutely uh that's a great
question
um we actually ended up using teams at
um which is which is Microsoft's kind of
slack Zoom thing you know it works then
I kind of like slack more for some
things like Zoom more for other things
but you know teams is what it is but you
know I would say the beginning of the
pandemic you know obviously at the
beginning we were all in person so a lot
of in-person meetings a lot of in-person
conversations uh a lot of you know a lot
of going to the third floor and having
to find a meeting room at the beginning
of like the online appraisal project now
it's mostly teams we did start using I
mean let me borrow this from like our
our it our technology Partners when we
were working on the online
um on the online product and the online
appraisal product was um what was it
called link it we started using link it
um as a which is a tool to kind of track
tasks and kind of have these Lanes of
tasks and you can make a card and assign
people to it and kind of move it from
you know the backlog to uh to working
now to finish this planned or discarded
or whatever so um lean kit is a tool
that my team uses uses a lot we didn't
when I started
um so it keeps kind of It kind of helps
us like you know one it helps you hey I
think we should you know redo this table
in a better way or whatever we'll make a
card for it and you know and you can
kind of help remind yourself to come
back and look at it later
um that's kind of we we also started
doing like at least for my team and this
is something that I don't know if it was
my idea or not but we did something we
did when I was at doe when I was at
Department of energy we would have a
morning tag up with them leadership
would all get together every day every
morning at like 8 30 which was miserable
uh 8 30 every day and I would always be
a few minutes late and and we would talk
to everyone talk about what they had
going on that day and I remember
bringing that idea to my boss and I
don't know if it was
inspired by that or just partially
related to that but we started doing
that at Carmax now we have like I think
most teams have like a daily Tag app
where you kind of and each one is kind
of structured differently one day we'll
look at link it one day we'll talk about
I'm looking at we'll review
um kind of open topics one day we'll
kind of look at this this um this uh
other kind of structure we use we're
going to talk about the weeks the week's
agenda and stuff
um so kind of that daily touch-up and
it's getting a little trickier as we
start going I think everyone on my team
is still like East Coast but I think
other teams are starting to get some
West Coast folks and 9 A.M standards
don't work if you've got someone on the
west coast right so um so I think one
team has moved there stand up to like
you know later in the day
uh but that seems to that seems to work
um
but I think it's mainly that ironically
we don't send a lot of emails like we
get a lot of automated emails like
talents like reports and like graphs and
like you know this model retrained and
stuff but we don't we don't actually I
don't get a whole ton of emails like
from my team most of everything is done
in teams for better for worse uh
different channels channels for for
support when things are breaking
channels for systems channels for like
just my team and the R D
um that seems to be the main thing it
wasn't really my call right like teams
was just kind of like for sure but I
think I think we figured out how to use
it pretty effectively in the you know
probably six months in the pandemic we
sort of had a good system going yeah it
sounds like it and uh it's really
interesting I I just mentioned in a side
chat here
um we are all working on the modern data
stack right like we are at kind of like
the Forefront of innovation and I feel
like a lot of teams just kind of go with
the the slack Zoom email communication
tools so it's great to hear that you
guys are trying something some other
stuff that works for you
we borrowed it from I mean it's not
really a communication tool it's more of
an organizational kind of project
management tool but we kind of borrowed
it from technology because we saw they
were using it our technology department
was using it we brought it into the
appraisal Lane and sort of filtered out
some other teams within pricing systems
and so that seems to be getting some
traction a lot of questions in here so
we can keep yeah
definitely I see um Marlene you had your
hand raised a bit earlier so I didn't
know if it was on this topic too if you
want to jump in
um it's on a
separate topic but okay go for it in the
chat before me so I'd like Daniel to go
first and then I can ask I've got to
stay real no before
so no there's no rules but yeah but I'll
come back to you in just a second here
hey Daniel do you want to jump in
sure yeah hey everybody hey Marcos I
really enjoyed the conversation so far
I'm just interested in hearing a little
bit more about unit testing that you
guys rolled into your work you know I
think it's one of those parts of
pipelining that is very like human
driven you know like what unit tests are
you think about like how are you
including them to your workflows you
know what's important for the kind of
work that the organization is doing and
just kind of interested to hear more
about you know what what are some
standard unit tests that you're working
on your teams working on what are some
non-standard unit tests like where you
roll with men how much time you spend on
them that kind of thing that's a great
question um so as I was arriving the
reason why my team my my bigger team the
core pricing system scene was talking
about unit test so much when I got there
is because they had kind of made a
decision to make sure they had 100
coverage of all their entire of our
entire code base and they weren't
because I think we just migrated to the
cloud this is another thing that
happened right before I got there like
everything had been running on-prem and
then we moved everything to running in
Azure and so I think as part of that
transition I think our unit test
coverage had plummeted or maybe it was
never Ai and it got lower so there was a
huge effort where everyone was kind of
just grabbing different pieces of code
and writing unit tests to cover all to
cover all the lines for people to know
what coverage is just in case you don't
know like you can basically run a
coverage report and like a test that you
run like four tests and the test will
like run this method and run that method
and run this you know function or
whatever and then the coverage report
will tell you well you never this line
has never been run right like you never
run this line or this conditional has
never been flipped because you never
this things never you know the price was
never less than ten thousand or whatever
um so there was a huge effort to get
full coverage which I was completely
clueless about because I didn't do the
test was so I get in there and everyone
was talking about unit tests all the
time and describing how I got this thing
to crash and I got this exception to be
caught Etc so basically our goal right
now is to kind of basically we have this
giant one unique thing that I should
point out is that what is I think unique
to the team I'm on and and
um at Carmax unique you need to this
team in CarMax is probably unique in
general and so we are very vertically
integrated like the team like the code
base that I can touch is can have code
that basically is wrapping around
machine learning but it can also have it
also has the code that is like running
24 7 in the cloud that is like hitting
Azure service bus right so we have like
this the deployment of the algorithm we
get really close to the deployment we
don't own like the cluster like we have
our technology Partners they're like own
like you know the actual Azure pods that
are running the stuff but like the code
that we run on that thing we own right
which is very unusual I think a lot of
data scientists kind of ride the machine
learning thing and kind of throw
whatever the walls to some production
team and it's not like that with us so
because of that because we have this
production code which we call like our
cluster code and we have like the code
that wraps our machine money models
which we call components like uh we have
we kind of have all that code and we can
basically run unit tests to try and
cover every single thing right so they
tend to be tend to be focused around
like uh at the you know uh um we also
have like wrappers for [ __ ] tables like
that we have like a wrapper that we've
written around [ __ ] so all these little
pieces of code basically the goal is to
kind of just make sure that every line
is covered there's been some debate
internally about what was the goal to
test like you know we don't have a lot
of tests that like run through the
entire pipeline like we don't have like
integration tested in the unit testing
there's been a lot of debates there'll
be ad things that are actually sending
the ping pong ball all the way down from
you know the raw request all the way to
going back or should we just kind of be
testing everything a little bit I think
we're more testing everything a little
bit but um
um but that is our goal and so like we
have like we have Valentine standards
that we added so we make sure that
everything is limited properly we have
and we have it's all automated so we can
run like we I think we finally put it
into uh what do you call it I don't know
how it works exactly because it's not my
thing but basically whenever we submit a
pull request like it automatically runs
all the unit tests and
it's good to we write them mainly to
make sure we didn't break something oh
you know that's that's the real goal
right but we also write so that then but
we also write them just to make sure
that every line is covered and so I
think it's more the more the goal
um but the idea is like if there's an if
there's a piece of code that runs an
algorithm then we run then we have unit
test it make sure that all works if
there's a piece of code that like takes
in
like a raw request we're all we're
getting is like
I don't know trying to think of some
some safe example to program but you
might imagine that the data we get the
payload that we get we might want to
look up auxiliary stuff like I don't
know I'm trying to think of something
that's that's that seems obvious uh um I
have to be careful because our all of
our Peach engineering secret uh but just
let's just look at like Levin can tell
you a lot of information about the car
right this is a good example right the
VIN of a car like has embedded in it
like the model year so say we got um a
VIN and but then when you decode the van
it's like modeling or 2012 but then
someone that the customer typed in model
year 2013. because they're like this
really happened but we would we would
have code that would look that up and
check there's two things against each
other and if the model gear and the VIN
disagree we could just reject it and
since it's not a valid request right so
that's code and we have to test all
those things as well so the goal is to
just kind of test every single little
method in class that we have it's not
super
integrated but it is
probably been talking for too long we're
getting a Tesla oh yeah
I feel like you're very passionate about
unit tests now too
um you are from not knowing them in the
beginning
because we used to have more formal code
reviews about everything and so like
what we should be test the content topic
of debate we talk about lesson
Marlene do you want to jump in now
sure
um so as somebody who's used CarMax
before by the way I'm always kind of
um the light bulb goes on when I realize
that some of the things that I've used
every day are actually machine learning
or an algorithm in the background right
you're like oh my God yeah that's that's
what we do in play and in practice so
that's really cool to hear that verified
right
um but uh my question was about
so with data projects in general right I
mean you've launched some pretty big
projects I mean as an organization
CarMax has right you've talked about a
few of them
um what does the and I'm interested from
anybody on the call by the way if you
want to throw your your organization's
kind of Mo in the chat but do you feel
that a project
kind of gets delved down to you from the
management team or does your team or
somebody maybe from one of the other
data science teams kind of start to
bring projects forward they get looked
at by management and then kind of get
the go-ahead back to kind of bottom up
or top down yeah exactly I think that
the goal I think the goal to do like we
want to we want to be able to praise
cars on the website was a
I don't know how high up it was but that
was a top down that was something that
came to us like we wanted we want to
figure out a way to do this to do this
and we're so it was a task given to us
but I think there are smaller things
where it is kind of bottom up like hey I
discovered this cool I discovered this
cool thing this is cool opportunity you
know I spice the data this way and you
know this bucket of cars is doing this
interesting thing so let's change let's
change how we do this algorithm let's
change how we do this whatever I can't
get too specific about it but there's
definitely things where you know people
are doing Discovery come up with
something come up with a new way to do
something maybe it's faster maybe it's
just more efficient and then that gets
pitched up and it's like yeah this is
better let's just do it right so it
definitely happens both ways I think I
think the bottom op tends to be smaller
components of a thing uh whereas like a
huge like idea let's say let's though
you could argue that the origin of CPS
which is like let's try and use
algorithms to help price cars that did
start bottom up like I can't I don't
think I'm allowed to tell that story but
like like the the person who came up
with hey let's try these algorithms to
to help us with our car price I think
that did that was bottom up and it was a
effort to convince like the organization
that like this is something that can
help us now that was well that was
before my time um but um so you could
argue that answers my question though
yeah I think it is a healthy balance of
both once you get it up and running
right right um I'm in a position where
there is no projects so I'm trying to
figure out where do I start do I get
management start brainstorming or do I
start bringing the data science team
along that I'm brand new like shiny
assembled to start to propose projects
to the management and start where do I
start that but I guess uh it's it's
anybody's guess right you just kind of
throw spaghetti off the wall and see
what sticks so I want to answer
absolutely I want to answer Libby's
question which I'm seeing before I
forget which is about sharing practices
and we actually just started using uh
stack Enterprise whatever the stack
Overflow software but private whatever
that's called I think it's called stack
Enterprise maybe and that's been uh we
had a Wiki that was based on GitHub you
know our on-prem GitHub and that never
seemed to work very well so now we've
kind of moved to this stack Enterprise
thing which we use both Karma I think
it's used both CarMax wide and then we
have one just for our CPS team uh and
and that's been been really pushing to
like every time someone asks a question
on teams like why don't you make a why
don't you make a stack answer that on
stack and so we've been trying to move
that way so that people can can share
but tends to be more technical things
like oh how do I do this you know how do
I install the SQL client right but
sometimes it is it is more like what do
these codes mean or what how do we you
know so we're trying to do that it's not
really best practices yet but it is it
is aware as acknowledge repository that
we're trying to use
I love it that's fantastic I've kind of
done that in other jobs where I've
gotten in and I realize people don't
have a way to talk to each other and
teach each other yeah so I've set up
like SharePoint messaging boards where
if it's after hours and you're doing
something you can ask and somebody else
can answer you it doesn't have to be me
the coach like during office hours
helping you you can help each other
right I was kind of wondering as a
addition to that if you had anything
that was
like knowledge sharing session like
maybe I don't work in the same area
here's what I'm working on so you can
get other people's brains we absolutely
do and as soon as you started saying
that I realized that I forgot other
thing we do which is uh this thing
called Data bytes uh which is our little
like it's kind of like a lunch and learn
sort of thing you know
um we it kind of it was going for a
while and then we kind of I think we
pause it over the summer but it's back
and this is a chance so we mentioned we
have these multiple teams within pricing
systems and this is a chance for us to
hear what other people have been working
on like you know what tools that they
use what things that they discover
um so like I think I presented a history
like it wasn't really done I think I
wasn't super technical but I presented a
little history of the online appraisal
product that we just talked about a
while ago other teams will talk about
their algorithms the new versions of the
algorithms they're working on and the
systems they're working on and this is a
way for us because why I mentioned the
collaboration is very deep like in time
inside the team and every now and then
you kind of touch like the other
appraisal the other pricing system teams
like there is another huh well I know
they're working on this thing but I
don't know how it works and so the whole
data bytes is to like get into the some
details like well this is how we set it
up this is how we're correcting it this
is the type of kinds of machine learning
models we're using this is the data we
trained it on why didn't you do why
didn't you try this well I didn't use
this much data you know that the whole
point is to kind of have a an open
discussion about this sort of thing
so it's really cool so yeah
my colleague Andrew has brought back the
data bytes I missed the last one because
I was in Texas it's a theme of the
episode
um but uh but it's a it's it's a really
good thing and I hope and we hope the
plan is to keep doing that kind of once
a month I think and kindly rotate
through the four teams that we have
cool I was just going to ask you how
often so once a month whenever I hear
some of the like names people come up
with I'm like jeez what did I think
about that that sounds really creative I
see um a lot of hands went up on one of
your last questions two so you you do
you want to jump in I don't know if you
wanted to add to one of the previous
ones or if you have a new question
hi hi
um yeah by the way if you remember we
had a discography fall um by the way my
house uh um we pick up data science from
oxygen Finance so my company works out
Works closely with your company CarMax I
believe we have several several programs
collaborated together and I just have
one question for you so you said that
you build algorithms you use models for
car pricing however you use these models
for car prices when we implemented how
do you mitigate the possible risk it
brings to the business decision because
we know that carbon already have similar
models for car pricing and didn't work
well I missed predict a lot they had to
lay off thousands of employees earlier
and earlier Silo they have similar
algorithms they predict a possible price
for house houses and they buy a lot of
houses I didn't work unwell either right
oh yeah that's a great question
um
those are great questions
um so how can I answer this because the
one thing I'm not supposed to talk about
in the details are algorithms um all I
can say is you just look at like our
success like look at our quarterly like
reports like you know we're I think we
reported in like our last like SEC
filing that we bought 300 000 cars like
online or something uh you know we make
money per car like I don't I don't want
to say our algorithms are better
um but I think I think we you know we
obviously monitor it like how we're
doing you know we can monitor you know
we we know we know what we bought the
car for We Know What It ultimately sells
for we can look we can cut that by a
bunch of different segments and so you
know we're there's definitely a a very
regular process by which we're looking
at our performance of of the company as
a whole our algorithms as a whole uh and
and really monitoring things very
carefully
um but if you just look in our case I
mean you know the stock price whatever
it's gonna the wall Street's gonna do
what it does but if you just look at
like how we've done in terms of like how
much money we're making like per car uh
you know we've been profitable
throughout this entire as far as I know
maybe I shouldn't and it's not stock
advice you know what it was that doesn't
have to make but you can just read our
read our reports and we seem to be
managed managing the risk very well
obviously it's been a crazy time you
know cars are appreciated and they
appreciate it I mean you've ever seen
all the headlines you know about about
about car prices they've been it's been
a crazy
three years I mean I basically basically
since we started this online appraisal
product nothing has been normal about
car prices and yet somehow you know
somehow we've made it work um yeah thank
you very much thank you Brian I see you
had your hand raised too jump is
oh yeah
yeah so on the uh bottom up versus top
down so I I've worked under both
um and it was interesting one
environment I worked in we were bottom
up and I come from a corporate finance
background so we did a couple things one
we waited the projects on
impact
um ease of doing and overall cost so so
we would present to our leadership the
people that were going to fund these
deals like project a high impact or low
impact ease of doing and how much it was
going to cost and if it was really big
um like a system-wide thing and we would
I would do like a five-year net present
value of costs and you do opportunity
costs and you do all the financials
um because at the end of the day is if
it's got to go to cfo's desk
you want to speak CFO
um and but it was an easy way to get for
like because our team would generate all
the ideas you know people be like hey I
want to do computer vision for this or
I'll do that or I'll do something
interesting with NLP and so we would
actually pitch them all with this sort
of waiting structures hey we can knock
this out in about a month or this is six
months and
um and oh but you may be able to
streamline this or change these kinds of
things so it's
um it's harder to just pitch ideas
without that to leadership I think
that's the takeaway from it all you
really got to give
value proposition across I think those
those elements
I agree with all that
thanks Ryan I was trying to remember and
I was writing this in the chat I I think
it was Darren
um who mentioned like this like
rubric or that they use to decide like
which product projects to work on too I
was trying to find it on the side but
again multitasking is difficult I'm
trying to keep up with the chat um I
think yeah I asked a question about my
time like program level was people later
um I would say and I've made a point to
try and I think I mentioned this in a
previous hangout in the chat that like I
feel like
finding time to focus on like you know
to like head down like actually like
doing coding or out or Discovery
whatever I want to keep that time so I I
started blocking out certain chunks in
my calendar to make sure that nothing
gets scheduled in those chunks uh so
that I can like you know head down focus
on you know doing some Discovery or or
maybe playing with a new algorithm or
looking at you know Trends or whatever
so I try and do that but you know I
think um you know obviously we have to
have meetings about you know with my
with my team about what we're trying to
do what is our goal I mentioned that we
have a daily tag up you know like I
mentioned
um we have you know what we call an ml
Optimum the ml Ops Team so that kind of
there's there's meetings I do do
interviews I do first round interviews
so there's good scheduled those good
jobs onto my calendar
um but I think I've probably it's
probably like 50 like you know kind of
all the service and stuff and then maybe
a little it depends on the week
obviously and then 50 where I can
actually like focus on either writing
code or trying to find a you know Soft
bug or what have you
um so kind of more technical stuff
um and then we do I do also help like I
I don't I don't manage people directly I
do you I am usually involved when we
hire new people and so I do try and
schedule time as you know with our new
folk like there's there's formal
training we do and formal review of like
some notebooks that we have for training
but how to access our data and how our
environment works but then there's also
kind of just check-ins with folks you
know after the fact like you know I'm
obviously always frequently available
just for people to ping me on teams but
I like to have like schedule like
check-ins like as people are getting
started with like hey what do you want
to talk about
how that will change is you know
titles change and and work and and my
role changes but for now it's it's a
pretty good balance it's also bounce
between systems and algorithms I
mentioned how we own this whole stack so
even within that 50 like probably half
of that is outward development and
looking at data and thinking about
machine learning and thinking about you
know algorithm design and fitting things
and predicting things and half and half
of half of the time is
you know systemy stuff like trying to
like you know think about the code and
think about the uh you know the more
systems aspects maybe not like we're
trying to yeah tell me about that
don't worry about the chat Marcos I
promise I will I'll collect the
questions
okay okay
um I see Timothy you had your hand
raised too if you want to jump in
all right thanks for the talk it's
really really great uh inspiration there
I'm gonna rewind a little bit to the
very beginning and sort of ask
um as someone who sees themselves in a
similar
keeping options open in terms of career
um
what was the
most effective asset that you had that
led to being able to transition to your
current position right that's a great
question I mean I think probably two
things one is like that that that
interest or or ability or willingness to
kind of like teach just try and teach
myself stuff like like I said I in
graduate school I've done a ton of data
analysis and stuff but like it was all
in this obsolete language that wasn't
going to help me right so I had to teach
myself Python and then I had to kind of
teach myself R
um and then eventually teachers with
more python
um so I mean I think just the the
openness to trying that and kind of I
gave myself a project you know to to
kind of figure out how to how to use
Python and understand classes and
object-oriented program and try to not
understand 10 years ago
um but then two I do think that my work
experience because I had you know I had
done a lot of non-technical stuff I do
think that probably helped I I don't
really know how that was all balanced
when I you know when I interviewed but I
did feel like I had this like record of
like professional accomplishment that
maybe it wasn't technical uh but
obviously I you know I had a people knew
I could write people knew I could thank
people I could read you know I had this
I had this track record so I think I
think like you know success even in my
previous jobs even if they weren't data
science jobs probably I would like to
think also helped
um okay thanks and the second part of
that is sort of a more like I guess
personal passion motivation thing is how
do you go from presumably you don't get
a PhD in astrophysics unless you
actually like yeah you know that like
stars or you know doing math about stars
how do you how did you translate do the
mental folding to translate that from
you know you spent many years doing this
to you know a different position you
know right that's a great question
that's probably my dad would like to
know the answer that he's like I thought
you wanted to be an astronomer like what
are you doing
um uh you know the first the first step
was not just data science of course it
was to the science policy world and I
think I had always had this interest in
politics in the government and uh and so
that first transition came because
someone when I was at Rice they have
these talk like once a month about
non-academic careers and someone who had
done science policy and worked like the
national academies of Science and had
worked as a congressional science fellow
came and gave a talk about what she had
done with her you know physics or
astrophysics degree I can't really I
think that's what she had
um and uh that really fascinated me this
guy could kind of combine these two
things and as I went through my postdoc
like I just found my brain not really
focused I mean I kind of enjoyed my
research and I was kind of enjoying my
wrapping up what I did my PhD on but I
wasn't super motivated by like the new
stuff I was working on as a postdoc so I
was relatively so even though I always
love astronomy and you know very happy
and I met a ton of great people in grad
school who were my still my friends
today
um you know it was pretty easy choice to
try and kind of pivot to this science
policy world and then from science
policy data science was more practical
right like you know and I needed a more
the once you get to the upper echelons
of the science policy world there's just
a number of jobs and openings become
fewer and fewer there's a ton of
jobs kind of sort of at the entry level
for science policy but as you start to
work your way up I was I was running out
of things today I was trying to become a
chief of staff at University it's like
two openings about a year so like you
know it's just it became more practical
right and then it turns out when I did
it I would start and I started itching
that part of my brain again and I really
enjoyed it like you know I enjoyed the
incubator I enjoyed trying to you know
uh do the swirl lessons in our enjoyed
building I built like some some shiny
apps and I was like very satisfied and
so I found that like once I got back
into doing technical stuff I find it I
found that scratching that itch was
still really satisfying
yeah thanks I really appreciate that I
I'm kind of in the same position where
I'm an academic you know clinical
research and it's like this pyramid
where it's like yeah it's like the you
they kind of get a little stuck and um
yeah it's really it's really nice to be
reminded that uh you can always life is
you know long journey and you can always
switch courses and it's you don't always
need to be looking at other people and
being like oh they did this by age 22 or
like you know they've been doing you
know it's like a straight trajectory to
some to success but I mean I mean you
could argue that CarMax did my first job
because it didn't have an expiration
date because all my previous jobs had
some kind of like if there were
fellowships right right yeah so you
could definitely argue this is my first
real job
it doesn't happen it doesn't have a
built-in expiration date like my
previous positions did well thank you
very much absolutely thank you Timothy
too I I see there's a lot of interest in
in this discussion too so I don't want
to leave this this topic here because I
see Gregory you asked a question and and
Allen plus one did as well Gregory do
you want to to jump in if there's any
follow-up you want to ask there too
can you hear me yep
oh I'm sorry Jack no no it's okay I see
them they're flipped on the chat
I mean I'm also in a very simple
position I think Timothy after
you know I'm in an academic world I've
moved into government and now I'm in
this position where I had an economics
degree
um finished that PhD and now I'm looking
to try to potentially move on and
utilize some of the ml skills that I
developed through the PHD to be able to
uh
um
you know more of a data science role one
reason I mean you mentioned some of the
things that you were trying to emphasize
and the things that we're interested to
employers or the very specific skills
that you were trying to sell to them or
um anything like that yeah I mean I
think I I mean so I was in this position
where I felt like my best selling point
was this well I've been you know I'm
trying to think think back so I did go
through the data incubator program which
uh uh kind of for better for worse like
when I was a fellow this is like three
years ago I don't know how they've
changed their business model exactly but
like I just basically didn't pay
anything to do the data incubator but I
had to go try and get placed with their
hiring Partners was kind of the way that
worked and so um and I was technically I
was I think it was only supposed to like
only supposed to interview with their
hiring partners for a while so so I had
this kind of like subset of like
employers I could work I could work with
and they helped me with my resume and
stuff but the end result was I felt like
my my my what made me a little different
everybody else was the fact that I was
you know had I wasn't a lot of my
colleagues they were fresh out of grad
school right I had worked 10 years I
felt like the bat
background how did I how did I phrase
that if working you know in a high
pressure and professional environment
you know tight deadlines you know that
that work experience was still relevant
even if it wasn't technical right so I
tried to sell that and I remember
talking to the founder of TDI who came
in for lunch with us and he told me to
try and try and talk up that aspect of
things but I also had sort of you know
yes I was new to being data science I
was new you know I recently learned our
and recent on this boot camp but I did
had done a very technical PhD right so
there's clearly you know data and
numbers statistics were not something
that like people were new to me right I
mean I had a bachelor's in astronomy I
had a PhD in astronomy I think that
helped too
um you know I can't you know I did a
bunch of interviews like uh and when I
came to TD I don't remember how they all
went they were all different you know
carmax's was not super
um
it was more about critical thinking
skills and like the kind of questions I
got asked were not like you know code
challenges whatever they were like
thinking through kind of
um thinking through more of like a more
like a Consulting sort of thing like a
case kind of interview uh and so uh but
I was mainly trying to say hey I did a
bunch of identity and I also I was all
experience from my PhD I have all this
work experience where I was working in
like you know
on type deadlines you know working for
important people you know doing like
it's interesting stuff right and now I
kind of refreshed all my technical
skills and like got to this data
incubator and I'm ready to go right uh
that's kind of how I package myself
um
um I know when we look at interview when
we look at resumes and look at
candidates now like you know we're
looking for analytical degrees
analytical mindset and you know it
certainly helps if you're applying for
data science world to have done
something it could be a bootcamp it
could be a side project it could be you
know some work experience uh some
volunteer experience but something that
you know you mentioned python pandas
machine learning so I could learn you
know um even you know uh things of that
nature right it's kind of the skills
we're looking for
um to get you know to get into the into
the door and then obviously you just
have to do well at the interviews
great thank you
that's great they had that that program
in place too though I know you've
mentioned like you're supposed to only
interview a certain like hiring yeah
managers but sounds like there are a lot
of companies they worked with
um I know Robert you asked a question a
bit earlier too do you want to jump in
yeah sure I was asking sort of how you
made the decision to use the Enterprise
service bus and whether or not that's
like your main way of sort of moving
data between services
um
you know did you could you have done
more like
you know Pi spark and airflow and you
went with the ESB instead or was there
also like an option for like message
cues like kind of right yeah
that's a very good question I don't I
don't think I think by the time I came
on board and was like looped in and read
into the to what we were doing the
decision had already been made we've
been using Azure message queues or I
think the storage based cues before and
I think I think to do the real-time kind
of stuff with uh with uh with the online
product we wanted to move to service bus
so it'll be easier to link you know our
response back to the incoming
um to the incoming request
um uh in a direct way and so we
partnered with technology so technology
kind of wrote like the you know the API
the rest API then they would send us the
service bus message and then we would
get it process it put a message back
send a message back and it would flow up
so I it's a great question I don't know
whether things were evaluated you know
we were kind of already we'd already
kind of moved to Azure I think there
were other teams kind of using service
bus for things so I unfortunately I I
was not kind of involved in that
decision I was basically like oh we're
using service bus I need to figure out
how the price on apis work I mean that's
that's kind of that's kind of where I
came in uh and ended up re not rewriting
but yeah rewriting a lot of our of our
code to handle service bus um
but um you know it worked it worked
pretty well for us you know um and it
was you know it's relatively
straightforward for us to um for us to
to process those requests you know
process cards and send the messages back
okay that makes sense thanks yeah
I just wanted to double check Tyler and
Hannah if there was anything over on
slido because I realized we didn't ask
any of the anonymous questions yet
none right now okay cool I love that
everybody's asking them here too
um
what was I just gonna ask you I lost my
train of thought oh when you were
talking about like using other
like using new tools that you saw that
were helpful for other teams
how do you like
start to like share those across the
company because I feel like that's
separate from like a conversation about
like
data science or like your process but
more of like right yeah big picture
those are good questions um you know
like you know I don't have too many
examples like the Lincoln example was
like we were trying to get like this
this online appraisal service up and
running we were partnering with our with
our partners in technology we're going
to kind of own the API and so we were
going to their meetings and looking at
their Lincoln board and my boss and I
were like it looks kind of neat and so
you know it turns out we had a nice
CarMax had a license for we were able to
get access to it and to start playing
around with it and it became and we you
know you kind of try it and see how it
works and then pretty soon we ended up
liking it and confusing it
um similarly with stack Enterprise I
think it was deployed we got like a
corporate emails saying hey we're using
we have stuck Enterprise now uh and then
I think we realized we can make like a
sub because again some of the stuff we
do it needs to be is a little more
confidential than other teams do so we
we're able to make like our own little
one of my colleagues uh on the ml Ops
Team realized we could make a sub
you know a team specific stack
Enterprise inside of the CarMax wide one
and then we created our own and then we
could answer questions in there that we
didn't want like the entire company to
be able to see so
um uh so that worked really well so so
far it hasn't been so far been those two
examples like it was relatively seamless
like we kind of already had access to it
we could already kind of we could
already kind of use it um uh uh other
you know they may be other maybe other
bottlenecks that I don't know about but
so so far it's been pretty easy to do
that
well yeah
just for myself I think sometimes it's
hard to know like what tools are
available within a company like there
may be a pocket of like or a group over
here that's using some tool that could
really help me but because we don't do
the same thing we don't talk about it
right yeah I mean we were this is again
kind of 2019 early 2020 pre-pandemic so
we were physically going to meetings
with these technology teams and we kind
of saw how they were mentioning their
their side of the project and that kind
of there's also something called a mural
I think someone one of the teams was
easy Mira that sort of Miro yeah uh so
that one didn't quite tick off as much
but we saw it and we tried it and you
know and we played around with it uh but
it didn't really kind of catch on with
our team the way Lincoln did yeah cool
yeah that's a question I love to ask the
group too if there is like a tool that
you're using across your team that you
really like or something you just didn't
know about before I love to get ideas
like a random one that I really like is
um this tool called like add event where
like I can like get people to like sign
up for meetups and they don't have to
like give me any details they can just
add it to their calendar but it's
something random I just learned about
from Robert on my team so it's just it's
just cool to hear about what people are
using
um I see let's see Luke
I see you had a comment in the chat do
you want to jump in
oh you can't
um I just want to make sure that I
didn't miss any questions here right
when I told you Marcos said you don't
have to worry about somebody there's fun
comments in the chat yeah no I'm still
waiting to chat I saw someone tell me to
stop looking at me in the chat and
that's why I was laughing earlier
busted I read the chat I liked our
conversation like Alan
about like um finding leadership
positions that are not people leadership
and how there are a lot of people
they've met in data science who are
really interested in finding these upper
levels and you kind of sounded like you
hit that in the policy space where
you're like there's nowhere else for me
to go I think data scientists hit that
frequently you found a sweet spot
um of like
half project management not really
people management
um do you see those in other
organizations or do you feel like yours
is pretty unique
um I think they're I think there are
examples of people of of kind of you
know mostly I see folks like me within
prices I can think of one person who
like you know I think it's me but more
singular than me uh who doesn't who
doesn't manage people but like still has
a very you know very a lot of autonomy
and a lot of a lot of of product
management but I think we are I think
all teams are uh and I think I would
assume it's having a lot of entities
trying to think more about this and this
exact question you're asking so I know
there are conversations happening I
think within within CarMax about like do
we have the right titles the right roles
the right the right career tracks for
for people that that that make sense you
know uh because you know the
um you know the the strategy world that
we're in is a lot more focused on you
know like it doesn't quite map I don't
think there's titles in those those
career tracks quite map on to like the
data science world so I think we're
thinking about that
um but um but yeah it's funny that my
titles manager I don't manage people and
so I get all these weird LinkedIn you
know messages about what you think they
think I can buy things they think I can
like hire people I mean I interview
folks but I don't like I get a lot of
messages that are completely
misunderstand what my title means it is
really funny
I see that there was a conversation
earlier in the chat about like if you're
maybe the only data scientist on a team
and you're trying to like get other
people on board or maybe they don't want
to come on board but
you might be feeling like in this lonely
like middle spot like do you have any
advice for people no that's a great I
saw I think I just saw that question I
don't I mean I think I'm really blessed
to be on a team that is like full of
data scientists and like you know you
know uh and and a really values data
science and so I'm not like the lone
data scientist who has to like try to
explain to people that we need to
install second learn or whatever we need
to use open source tools like everyone
these battles might have been fought in
the past before I got there but like
ultimately like I mean there are some
analysts on core pricing systems of
course but like there's a ton of data
scientists we're all
we're all trying to do data science
we're all you know they're super
flexible in terms of what kind of tools
we can we use these virtual wise
machines in the clouds it's super easy
to install new things they don't have to
get permissions like try I mean I just I
learned about streamlit ironically at
the art studio conference but I never
heard of uh I never heard streamer
before and uh and of course I heard
about Chinese uh shining for python uh
and uh you know if I want to install
this my jump box and try and I'm sorry
def box and and play around with those
like uh it was easy to do and then I can
say hey let's get this installed on all
the new ones as we make them and so um
uh so I'm just very it's it's a very
fortunate situation I I don't have I
I've noticed that as a theme of some of
these meetups that there's like the loan
person who wants to like you know switch
to use r instead of instead of uh uh you
know Excel or whatever and I think you
know for better for worse like it's not
a problem I've encountered I've been
very lucky at CarMax
great thank you
um so we used to ask this quite a bit
and I don't know it kind of fell off
where we stopped asking but I'm curious
are there certain resources or podcasts
that you find really helpful in the
space and like just staying up to date
on things that's a great question you
know it's funny I I've started following
more people on um on Twitter I don't
really have a great my Twitter presence
is super chaotic like I have like a
bunch of accounts and like my main
account I'm kind of anonymous on because
I don't want people to know what I say
but like I though I have a world I have
a world right I made a world bot like a
while ago that just to just tries to
solve portals right and it has like 40
followers uh and but but it's but it's
linked to my GitHub so like everyone
knows that's me so I started following a
bunch of uh a bunch of like I follow you
on the from that account Rachel and like
other folks and I started trying to
follow more people who who tweet about
data science and stuff and that actually
has been kind of interesting I think I
found people from from the com from your
conference from their Studio conference
and you know I've heard people talking
about duck DB and I started playing with
duck DB and how it works with parquet
files I'm like oh that's kind of neat so
that has been like lately it's been like
just kind of seeing people with people
retweet I started following the quarto
pub like there's an account that
retweets every tweet that mentions
quarto and that's been interesting
Rabbit Hole to chase people down that
way and see who's using Porto and what
they do
um unfortunately don't have a bunch of
podcasts to listen to I tend to like
get an idea of something I want to do as
like a side project and then I just
start trying to like learn how to do it
as opposed to like oh I should watch
this good but these you know to be
honest this event and some of your other
uh meetups have been have been
eye-opening in that way
um and and of course the ironically you
know the rco conference itself is how I
found this this event and a lot of other
things but um now I don't have a lot of
podcasts um uh that I uh data science
podcast I listen to
um uh but I am finding I am finding
Twitter is starting to be useful
following other people on Twitter has
been has been an interesting exercise
and learning more about tools people use
cool yeah I was trying I was trying to
remember in my head like how we first
got connected and I think it was from
the r Studio conference too but as you
think about like some of these other
tools or things you're finding out about
is there something you're like most
excited about in a year ahead
um I always ask this question people and
every time you ask it to other books
I've been like what am I going to say
when she asks yeah uh and unfortunately
I don't have a great answer I mean I
just I feel like you know I mean you
know we are in a position at Carmax
where like you know we are and to me
like the most interesting things are
these like visualization tools like I
think I'm kind of excited about showing
for python to see to see where that goes
you know I use Dash a lot uh I'm always
curious to see how that evolves uh I've
just discovered streamlined so like
trying to trying to start to take some
of these emails and even quarto you know
I've been playing around with quarto I
love you know I've been trying to get
that up and running and maybe I have a
fantasy in the future I can use that to
kind of generate some some static web
pages that we can share you know reports
and things across the team so those kind
of like
you know taking the data and the stuff
that I would do in a notebook and kind
of making it accessible to even on
data science not python users those tool
sets can do that are exciting whether
it's whether it's shiny whether it's
Dash whether it's Streamlight whether
it's quarto like things like that to me
are really interesting because like we
like I said a lot of my team with data
scientists but like if I want to share
someone a Dash app right now they
basically have to run it themselves they
have to clone it and run it themselves
like on their own computer when I would
love to be able to like give someone a
link and be like hey so we're working
we're trying to work towards that uh in
the future
um and quarto is a great thing because
we can I think we'll be able to use I'm
hoping that at some point we all these
quarter like render some nice
interactive reports with like nice
interactive crafts and drop it onto a
web server and then anyone can go look
at it so I'm kind of excited about that
is the rest of the team kind of on board
with
using like streamlined and dash too or
they're they're there's various levels
enthusiasm people are always Impressions
my apps like I think I haven't convinced
people I've only convinced one person to
to write well they commits one or two
people to write their own apps
um and that one person was really into
it I think uh left recently so um but as
uh so we'll see we'll see how it takes
off I think people always think it's
cool when I do it but I have to see
other people to write their own it's
been a little a little harder
yeah I'm always I'm always curious about
about like people
love the output or or love like a shiny
app or extremely app that you you create
but like what's what's the best way to
get them to like take that and maybe
make their own from it too or is that
just rely on somebody being curious
enough to to take it and do that
is one more question I'm just curious is
there something you thought that we
would all ask you today or something you
were like preparing for us to to ask you
that you want to share with us I don't
think so I uh I was worried I would have
enough talk about and so I wasn't that
wasn't a problem got a ton of questions
so that's that was great I'm glad
everyone was engaged I um I I do love
that you call like me a coast like the
guitar I'm like wearing your guests or
your co-hosts and like we're here to
kind of part of it in and get
interesting conversation started so I
really like that about the uh about the
Hangouts thank you I don't even know if
I was intentional about that in the
beginning but now I'm definitely going
to make sure I keep doing that thank you
so much for joining us Marcos really
really appreciate it thank you that's
great I'm gonna draw I can I've done it
before and I can do it again but we do
have openings on my team like oh yes
let's see if I can drop uh I think this
this event's about to end but I can drop
some links on LinkedIn or just search
any any job that says pricing uh whether
it's systems or pricing algorithms uh
that's posted anywhere those are those
are on my team are tangential to my team
so I can I'll drop some links on
LinkedIn group cool awesome yeah and if
you well I'll grab them from LinkedIn
too but I'll share them with the
recording here so if you're somebody
watching this in the future the links to
those jobs will be in the recording
details below too thanks everybody have
a great rest of the day thanks everyone
have a great day